hello there just before we get into
today's video why not check out a new
channel from me called wara graphics
want to know all the details about some
of history's most famous battles and
wars come join me on war graphics from
sherman's march to the sea to operation
barbarossa if it's got people fighting
each other we'll cover it there is a
link below i hope to see you over there
and now today's video
the early 20th century gave way to the
rise of the professional criminal the
mafia took america by storm becoming the
most dominating criminal faction in the
country made by the arrival of
prohibition and the great depression and
supported by a rigid internal structure
superior numbers and copious amounts of
bribes and firepower they showed that
law enforcement was oftentimes powerless
to stop them but at the same time came a
different breed of criminal with tommy
gun in hand they busted through the
doors of banks gas stations and grocery
stores and made off with the loot before
the police were onto them and then
traveled to the next town where the
performance was repeated again and again
and again until the inevitable end came
often in a head of bullets they were not
interested in building an empire based
on bootlegging drugs prostitution and
racketeering they just wanted money and
they wanted it fast they often were lone
wolves or worked in small gangs and
spent their time either on the road or
hiding from the law in sleepy little
motels most importantly they lived life
according to their own rules so it's not
surprising that the public became
fascinated with them and heavily
romanticized their actions the fbi
adopted a new term to describe these
criminals public enemies but then along
came john dillinger bank robber
extraordinaire and the government needed
a better phrase to describe the most
wanted most dangerous man in america so
john dillinger became public enemy
number one
john herbert dillinger also known as
johnny and jack rabbit was born on the
22nd of june 1903 in indianapolis
indiana the second of two children to
john wilson dillinger and mary ellen
lancaster his mother passed away of a
stroke when johnny was three years old
and so his sister audrey took on the
maternal role and raised him since she
was 13 years older than him meanwhile
his father remarried when dillinger was
knight to a woman named elizabeth fields
who proved to be quite caring and
affectionate towards her step children
all in all dillinger had a decent
upbringing he lived in a quiet middle
class neighborhood his father was strict
and somber but also made sure that his
family were always provided for he tried
to instill a moral code into his
children but little johnny showed his
rebellious streak from an early age and
was known around the neighborhood as a
troublemaker later when he became a
teenager johnny led a neighborhood gang
called the dirty dozen and already he
showed signs that he was more james bond
villain than just your average school
bully one day he and a friend kidnapped
a boy and took him to the local wood
mill where they tied him up on the table
with a circular saw and turned it on
slowly pushing him towards the saw they
eventually stopped and let the boy go
but not before scaring the living
daylights out of him johnny first got
into trouble with the law when he and
his gang were caught stealing coal from
pennsylvania railroad cars and reselling
it in the city he was taken to juvenile
court where he displayed the same
contempt for authority that he showed
his father even so the judge was of the
boys will be boys mentality and let
dillinger off the hook following a stern
lecture probably with some finger
wagging involved because we all know
that that works perfectly seeing his son
set on a path of destruction john
dillinger senior decided to move the
family to a small town hoping that it
was the glitz and glamour of the big
city that was making johnny act
recklessly therefore the dillinger sold
all their property in indiapolis and
moved to a farm in mooresville indiana
the rural change of scenery did nothing
to quell johnny's rambunctious spirit by
christmas he had dropped out of high
school and started spending most of his
time in the pool halls of the nearby
city of martinsville occasionally
heading back to indianapolis in 1923
johnny got into trouble with the law
again when he was pulled over after
stealing a car for a joyride he tried to
bluff his way out of it but he could see
that the officer wasn't buying it so he
made a run for it on foot now that he
was wanted by the cops dillinger knew
that he couldn't return home so instead
he enlisted in the united states navy it
probably won't shock you to find out
that john dilliger didn't exactly thrive
in the strict disciplinary environment
of the armed forces he served for a few
months on board the uss utah one of the
battleships that would be destroyed
during the attack on pearl harbor two
decades later before jumping ship while
docked in boston and going awol just
five months into his naval career johnny
received a dishonorable discharge and
returned to indiana 1924 was a pretty
big year for dillinger first off he got
married in april to 16 year old beryl
hovius the two of them moved out to his
father's farm and relocated to
martinsville where they lived with
beryl's parents johnny found work as an
upholsterer and even developed a budding
sports career as a shortstop for the
martinsville baseball team but even
though dillinger occasionally dabbled
with the idea of a regular honest life
it never really stuck and he had two
more run-ins with the law that year
first he was caught with 41 stolen
chickens but he managed to get off
without any serious repercussions the
same thing can't be said for his second
arrest though on september the 6th 1924
dillinger and a friend he met on the
baseball team ed singleton decided to
rob a grocer named frank morgan
dillinger armed with a 32 caliber pistol
and an iron bolt wrapped in a
handkerchief attacked morgan on his way
home while singleton waited in the
getaway car even though dillinger
delivered several blows with the bolt
the grocer fought back and made a lunge
for the pistol the weapon went off
during the struggle and even though
nobody had been hit this caused johnny
to make a run for it only to discover
singleton had already driven away when
he heard the shot both men were arrested
because dillinger had no criminal record
he was convinced by his father and the
local prosecutor that he would receive
leniency if he pled guilty
this was a mistake the judge was not
taken in by johnny's wiley ways and he
threw the book at him giving the 21 year
old dillinger the maximum sentence of 10
to 20 years in prison meanwhile
singleton received less than two years
but he had his own gruesome reckoning
one night when he drank himself into a
stupor and passed out on the train
tracks only to have his head completely
turned to mush by a passing freight
[Music]
train to absolutely nobody's surprised
dillinger was anything but a model
prisoner he got into fights he destroyed
prison property he gambled he smuggled
and he tried to escape several times
only to be caught soon after his own
instance in solitary confinement or time
added to his sentence but after a while
dillinger stopped caring his wife had
left him but he had made some new
friends in prison a clique of
like-minded criminals who spent all day
planning and fantasizing about all the
banks they were going to rob once they
were free ultimately they would become
known as the dillinger gang after their
most famous member although this name is
a bit misleading since john nillager was
rarely the guy who called the shots and
sometimes the gang even operated without
him the dillinger gang didn't really
have an official leader but unofficially
the position belonged to a man named
harry pierpont he had the charisma the
intelligence and the experience to fit
the bill and even though he was only a
year older than john dillinger he
already had led a different gang and
committed around 10 robberies before the
two met in prison pierpont acted as a
mentor to some of the other inmates such
as dillinger but he was not a fan of the
spotlight so is perfectly happy with
taking a step back and letting other
members soak up the notoriety and
adulation over the course of its
existence the gang contained about a
dozen members but we're just going to
mention some of the other notable gunmen
such as john red hamilton and lester
gillis better known to the world as
babyface nelson almost all of the gang
would meet a violent death by the end of
1934 whether in shootouts or in the
electric chair this was hardly the
career with the best retirement plan but
that was still a ways away from now at
the moment the gang members were still
locked up tight inside the indiana state
prison in michigan city the problem was
that the state wasn't simply going to
release them all at the same time in
fact some of them weren't scheduled to
breathe the sweet air of freedom for
quite some time and so if they wanted to
go bankrobbing together and start
wreaking havoc on the outside they
needed to be more proactive with their
efforts to simultaneously release
everyone so they came up with a plan it
was fairly straightforward it involved
smuggling in some guns and bribing some
of the guards who were amenable to such
persuasions to look the other way when
the right time came of course for this
to work they needed money for guns and
for bribes which they could not get in
prison that meant that the plan depended
on one of them getting released and
going on a robbing spree to finance the
other's escape and while that person was
none other than john dillinger
[Music]
in may 1933 dillinger was paroled after
eight and a half years in prison and he
was given the task of putting the money
together to fund the prison break but
dillinger was the most inexperienced
member of the group he might have spent
the last decade talking about bank
robberies but he never actually
committed one the others taught him
everything they knew and pierpont puts
him in contact with some of his
accomplices on the outside but we all
know there's no substitute for
first-hand experience this is why
dillinger's first robbery wasn't exactly
headline news just a couple of weeks
after his release he and his cohorts hit
a supermarket and walked away with the
kingly sum of a hundred dollars at this
rate it would have been faster if the
remaining gang members simply served
their sentences but fortunately for the
budding dillinger gang johnny was a fast
learner the second target the new
carlyle national bank in ohio was a
smashing success and the robbers made
off with ten thousand dollars that was
quickly followed by a supermarket
robbery worth another 3600 and then
another string of robberies all across
ohio and indiana dillinger proved to be
a natural and before long he was
entering every bank with the cool
swagger that made him famous around the
entire country but despite the way he
was often portrayed in the media we
might as well point out here that the
robin hood image that he crafted and
promoted for himself was pure fiction
dillinger was a ruthless and violent man
who got into shootouts with the law used
innocent bystanders as human shields and
never did anything but line his own
pockets with the money that he stole
after a profitable summer crime spree
dillinger had saved enough money for the
prison break so he and his accomplices
went to work still receiving
instructions from pierpont from behind
bars one collaborator handled the bribes
another one secured an apartment where
the escaped men could lay low
dillinger's job was to smuggle the guns
into prison which he most likely did by
hiding them in a package destined for
the shirt factory where pierpont worked
the escape attempt was tentatively
scheduled for the end of september but
the best laid plans of mice and men do
often go awry the prison break itself
went pretty well on september 25th 1933
around 10 or so inmates led by pierpont
used pistols smuggled in by dillinger to
take the guards hostage and make their
way through each section of the prison
catching everyone unaware and taking
more hostages along the way outside the
prison the inmates split into two groups
stole a few culls from a nearby gas
station and drove off eventually after
losing the cops they reunited with the
rest of their accomplices in their safe
house in hamilton ohio but they soon
noticed that somebody was missing where
was johnny as it happened just a few
days earlier dayton police had caught up
to jillinger after he robbed a bank in
bluffton they'd arrested him and he was
currently in the county jail in lima
ohio awaiting trial now a different gang
of crooks might simply have enjoyed
their own freedom and let dillinger take
the fall alone but this bunch was loyal
if nothing else and pierpont immediately
went to work on a new plan this time to
get dillinger out of lockup this one
wasn't as sophisticated as the first one
after all the lima jail was hardly a
maximum security facility on october
12th pierpont and three accomplices
russell clarke charles mackley and harry
copeland entered the jail posing as
indiana officials there to take
dillinger back to the state prison in
michigan city the only people present
were the sheriff his wife and a deputy
so when the sheriff asked to see their
credentials pierpont simply pulled out a
gun and shot him in the stomach the
others got the cell keys and freed
dillinger they locked everybody else
inside the cell and let the sheriff
bleed to death as they made their
getaway finally reunited the dillinger
gang was officially open for business
[Music]
once the gang was out in full falls they
began their crime spree in earnest
hitting around one bank per month on
average traveling up and down the
midwestern united states on two
occasions both in indiana they were also
successful in attacking and raiding
police arsenals to steal machine guns
rifles bulletproof vests and ammo so
they were probably the most well-armed
and dangerous gang active in the country
they also made it abundantly clear that
they were not afraid to use the arsenal
that they had at their disposal no fewer
than 13 law enforcement officers were
killed in shootouts involving the
delinquent gang or their associates
dillinger himself was responsible for
the murder of patrolman william patrick
o'malley who was gunned down in january
1934 during the robbery of the first
national bank in east chicago indiana in
response to these actions the chicago
police department established a new unit
of elite soldiers dubbed the dillinger
squad with the sole intent of bringing
down the criminals dead or alive despite
this it was actually the police in
tucson arizona that managed to capture
the notorious gang with a hefty dose of
good luck at the start of 1934 the gang
thought that the midwest was getting a
bit too hot for them so maybe it was
time for a change of scenery they headed
south of florida and then traveled west
all the way to arizona in late january
some of the gang members were hiding out
at the hotel congress in tucson when it
caught fire they were forced to leave
immediately abandoning their suitcases
one of the criminals even tried to pay
the firefighters to go into their rooms
and retrieve their luggage but this idea
blew up in his face when one of the
firefighters who was a detective story
buff recognized him and alerted the
police the robbers were arrested that
same day neither dillinger nor pierpont
was among them but the authorities
correctly surmised that they would be
close by hiding in different hotels
pierpont was caught during a staged
traffic stop while dillinger was
arrested by police officers waiting in
his bungalow just like that almost the
entire crew was in custody so well was
this the end of the dillinger gang no
not by a long shot with their crimes
spread out over such a large area now
came the legal battle over where they
would be tried in dillinger's case it
was eventually settled that it be sent
to the county jail in crown point
indiana where he would be tried for the
murder of officer william o'malley if
tillinger was already famous this is
where he became a superstar the media
followed him everywhere and he was even
allowed to attend one press conference
where he was lavished with the kind of
attention that would make you think it
just won the world series or cured polio
cameramen and photographers captured
every moment even asking at one point
for the police officers to pose
alongside with dillinger which
shockingly they totally did dozens of
officers and police vehicles were on
hand to make sure that dillinger reached
the jail in crown point reputed to be
escape proof and honestly calling
anything that is just asking for trouble
because on march the 3rd 1934 john
delinger proved the contrary when he
escaped how exactly he did it still
remains uncertain but he got his hands
on a gun somehow some say it was real
and was smuggled in others say that it
was a toy wooden gun dillinger liked to
brag that he carved himself either way
he used it to take hostages and make his
way through the prison before replacing
it with some tommy guns that were
definitely real and freeing another
convict named herbert youngblood who was
eager to get in on the action together
the two of them plus a deputy and the
prison mechanic drove off in the
sheriff's car after a few hours of
driving the car stopped on the side of
the road and the two hostages were let
go delinquent gave them a few bucks to
make their way back to town and with a
big criminal on his face he told them i
remember you at christmas unbeknownst to
linger however that was one promise that
he would not be able to keep
[Music]
following this prison escape the fbi
which was still known as the boi back
then or bureau of investigations got
involved because dillinger finally
committed a federal offense when he took
a stolen car over state lines on the
other side of the law things went back
to normal most of the original gang
members were behind bars including harry
pierpont who was executed in the
electric chair later that same year all
except red hamilton who got busy and
assembled a new crew consisting of
babyface nelson and his associates once
dillinger escaped he joined up and got
back to what he did best robbing banks
but not for long though because the heat
was definitely turned up a notch now
that the fbi was involved just two weeks
after his prison break dillinger was
involved in a shootout with the feds in
saint paul minnesota where one of his
accomplices was killed and dillinger
took a bullet in the leg another
shootout occurred in wisconsin at the
little bohemia lodge and then red
hamilton was killed in a third shootout
in hastings minnesota dillinger was
starting to feel the net titan around
him and in may he had some off the books
plastic surgery done hoping that he
could flee the country with his
ill-gotten gains on the road dillinger
preferred to travel with his girlfriend
billy frechette but in early april she
was arrested and charged with harboring
a criminal this made dillinger act
recklessly even more so than usual at
least until he met a new girl while
hiding out in chicago her name was polly
hamilton and she was a teenage runaway
he worked as an occasional prostitute
and a brothel owned by romanian
immigrant anna sage today more famously
known as the woman in red hamilton might
have been taken in by dillinger's charms
but sage not so much once she realized
who he was she was mainly thinking of
the reward money and a green card she
reached out to the fbi once a deal was
struck sage revealed that she and the
couple would be going to see a movie at
the bargraph theatre on the evening of
july the 22nd 1934 and so they did
fittingly it was a gangster flick titled
manhattan merlot drama starring clark
gable but once the movie was over
dillinger exited the theater right into
an fbi ambush he noticed the trap as it
was sprung but it was too late dillinger
reached for his gun but agents shot him
before he could pull it out injured but
still walking he tried to flee into an
adjacent alley but was gunned down by
the g-men finally killed by a bullet
that entered through the back of the
neck passed through his brain and exited
out his right eye the first ever public
enemy number one was dead although
there's a myth still prevalent today
which says that their man was a
look-alike and that the real dillinger
did manage to escape as for anna's age
she got her money but was still deported
she became an integral part of john
dilligen's legend as the woman in red
even though she was actually wearing an
orange dress that night to help the fbi
spot them easily someone scribbled an
epitaph for john dillinger on the
sidewalk where he collapsed it said
stranger stop and wish me well just say
a prayer for my soul in hell i was a
good fellow most people said betrayed by
a woman all dressed in red
[Music]